[Music]
World Cup soccer that's a big deal that
started today and here's a story that's
interesting several teams have forbidden
their players from having sex during the
World Cup did you know that yeah they're
forbidden have sex yeah wow so I guess
during college that was technically a
World Cup soccer star that's funny to
you huh I didn't think it was so funny
hey America's in the World Cup did you
even know that those Woo's meant no we
didn't experts say the US soccer team
has less than a 1% chance of winning the
World Cup and even their coach has said
winning is not realistic yeah all of
which sounds like one hell of a pregame
pep talk we got less than a 1% chance
and it's not realistic now get out there
very high crime rate in Brazil where
they're holding the place very dangerous
place Brazilian officials have asked all
tourists not to fight or scream if they
get mugged they did yeah they've also
asked people to please not die if they
get murdered you worry about that big
story since House Majority Leader Eric
Cantor lost surprise shocking loss since
he lost to an anti-immigration candidate
many Republicans are feeling more
pressure now to take a harder stance on
immigration in fact the Republicans are
so paranoid
today Chris Christie sent back his
chimichanga
yes you're allowed to laugh at
chimichanga yes go ahead let it out the
chimichanga came to his table right and
he really wanted it but he was scared he
sent it back yeah
very proud of that joke very proud
it had the word chimichanga yeah I love
it
chimichanga yep now the book I have says
chimichangas always funny yeah a book
must now when you say it like that
hey today Texas Governor Rick Perry said
that being gay is like being an
alcoholic yeah yeah he said in both
cases you're sipping something you
shouldn't how are we doing be good yeah
I think we're coming together nicely
here we're really pulling together
former President George HW Bush turned
90 today and he celebrated by going
skydiving so if you include Obama there
were two presidents in freefall today
[Applause]
[Laughter]
according to a new study the number of
car crashes linked to marijuana has
risen gone up yeah fortunately when the
cars crashed they were all going 8 miles
per hour
[Applause]
in Florida a couple has been accused of
making meth in a public library isn't
that crazy
Florida has a library
[Applause]
[Music]
a team of scientists has recreated a
deadly virus resembling the 1918 Spanish
flu that killed 50 million people they
recreated it yeah this team of
scientists is known as a bunch of dicks
[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell he doing that killed a lot
of people let's recreate it let's hit
the lab and make some yeah and shoot it
around in a firehose